monsieur monsieur le ministre des
Transports que se passe-t-il à la SNCF
que va faire la SNCF nous savons bien
que vous n'êtes pas le président de
cette entreprise publique mais enfin
l'État en est l'actionnaire unique
en général 5% des trains annulés c'est
ce qu'on appelle un trafic normal à la
SNCF mais nous constatons tous que
depuis quelques semaines et de quelques
mois la situation se dégrade je vais
prendre l'exemple d'une région que je
connais bien celle des Hauts de France
en plus des retard depuis le mois
d'avril c'est prêt d'un train sur 10 en
moyenne et chaque jour qui est annulé ce
qui crée un climat de tension et
d'anxiété pour les usagers et évidemment
et notamment ceux qui travaillent la
raison principale qui est invoquée c'est
le manque de personnel on peut aussi et
notre collègue fait pointer le
sous-investissement chronique dans le
réseau secondaire depuis 30 ans
ce manque d'anticipation de la part de
dirigeants d'un grand groupe public
paraît aberrant comment en sommes-nous
arrivés là et comment la situation va se
rétablir
monsieur le ministre la SNCF prend de
plein fouet la hausse des prix
d'électricité quid du bouclier tarifaire
pour protéger les voyageurs de la hausse
du prix des billets
déjà que nous savons que le train n'est
pas forcément plus attractif que la
voiture ou l'avion au moment où la
France prend des engagements à la cop27
on ne peut pas se satisfaire que le
moyen de transport le plus écolome en
CO2 soit financièrement le moins
intéressant
j'ajoute que les régions en charge des
TER sont censés je dis bien censés avoir
un dialogue quotidien avec la SNCF elles
sont confrontées à un manque de
transparence de la part de l'entreprise
et aussi de ce qu'on peut appeler le
Triangle des Bermudes de la SNCF c'est à
dire une organisation enfin une
désorganisation plutôt où il y a
tellement d'interlocuteurs on ne sait
plus qui fait quoi on ne sait plus qui
vous répond et personne ne sait vous
dire oui ou non monsieur le ministre
comment retrouver cette relation de
confiance entre les régions et la SNCF
comment rétablir l'offre de train et
comment la SNCF va répercuter ou pas la
hausse du coût de l'énergie sur le prix
des billets merci
cher collègue monsieur le ministre
Clément bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vergelen vous avez raison je
n'ai pas l'habitude de fuir mes
responsabilités nous parlons d'un grand
service public qui l'entreprise
entièrement public et donc cela ne peut
pas rester sans réponse ou faire face à
un quelconque désintérêt de la part de
l'État c'est la raison pour laquelle je
l'ai dit la situation est de France est
inacceptable et nous avons eu un
entretien puisque les TER sont
effectivement la charge des régions avec
le président Xavier Bertrand je me suis
rendu à Lille dès lundi et je me suis
sur entretenu hier avec le président
farando une nouvelle fois il y a un
effort exceptionnel de formation qui est
fait pour compenser ce que vous avez
décrit c'est-à-dire une pénurie de
conducteurs qui malheureusement parce
que cela fait partie des métiers en
tension ne concerne pas que la région
des Hauts-de-France mais concerne très
fortement très douloureusement les
usagers des Hauts de France aujourd'hui
il y a un plan qui a été tout à fait
exceptionnel qui a été mise en place ces
derniers mois qui prévoit en 2022 2023
le recrutement inédit de 440
collaborateurs TER en haut de France
mais j'ai demandé aux prises en phare en
loup face à la gravité de la situation
un exceptionnel d'urgence et
d'accélération de ces recrutements par
tous les moyens possibles qui sera
présenté par l'entreprise dans les
prochains jours en lien avec la région
car cette situation ne peut rester sans
réponse je l'ai dit très honnêtement une
situation de cette nature ne se règle
pas en quelques jours elle ne se résout
pas totalement en quelques semaines mais
nous devons montrer les améliorations
visibles sérieuses dans les toutes
prochaines semaines pour les usagers
vous avez parlé aussi de la question
tarifaire cela doit mérite mérite pardon
quelques précisions d'abord les tarifs
qui sont justement ceux du TER et de
beaucoup de trains des quotidiens ne
relève pas de l'État les tarifs en
revanche qui sont ceux des trains à
grande vitesse ou les trains d'équilibre
du territoire sont de niveau national du
ressort national c'est dans ce contexte
que j'ai demandé pour ces trains à la
SNF te mettre en place un bouclier
tarifaire qu'est ce que cela signifie
concrètement cela signifie que nous
devons d'abord agir pour réduire les
charges de la SNCF c'est ce que fait
l'état par les mesures que nous prenons
sur la maîtrise des coûts de l'énergie
qui a permis de réduire très fortement
le montant qu’évoquait devant le Sénat
le président farondoux près de 2
milliards d'euros nous ne sommes plus du
tout dans ces ordres de grandeur ensuite
d'avoir des hausses qui sont en toute
état de cause inférieure à l'inflation
et troisième point de préserver ceux qui
ont le plus besoin du train les ménages
modestes les utilisateurs réguliers
notamment pour le travail c'est pourquoi
j'ai demandé un effort tout particulier
sur les abonnements et sur les wigos ce
plan sera présenté là aussi dans
quelques jours par la SNCF je vous
remercie si monsieur
[Musique]